uh some more breaking news this morning
the disgraced pop star Gary Glitter has
been freed from prison after serving
half of his 16-year sentence the 79 year
old was jailed for 16 years in 2015 for
sexually abusing three schoolgirls it's
believed the singer whose real name is
Paul Gad will have to wear a tag and
tell officers when he is planning to
leave the country
Sky's Becky Cottrell is in The Newsroom
for us Becky he was imprisoned for some
very serious crimes do we know why he
has been released early no indication
yet as to why he's only served half of
this 16-year sentence but as you
mentioned there will be a license
conditions that he will be subject to
now upon his release just a warning some
of the details that I'm about to discuss
are upsetting and will be particularly
disturbing for some people so viewers
should bear that in mind he was jailed
for abusing three school girls and the
allegations against him only came to
Light 40 years after the events had
taken place when he became the first
person to be arrested as part of
operation yew tree which was an
investigation launched by the
metropolitan police after the
allegations and the scandals surrounding
Jimmy Savile now these school girls two
of the victims were just 12 and 13 and
they had been lured back stage by
glitter after one of his performances
the third victim not even 10 years old
when glitter tried to rape her back in
1975. now when he was sentenced for
these crimes the judge had spoken about
the understandable profound effect on
the victims but also that Glitter was
only able to access these victims and
commit these crimes because of his Fame
glitter's true nature was already known
about he had been jailed for possessing
child pornography images he'd been
banned from Cambodia for allegations of
sex crimes jailed in Vietnam as well but
now after serving this half of this
16-year sentence in the UK he is out of
prison